also peter we're getting a big update
that apparently
magnus has made a huge blunder and
dewbomb
has found a way to end cash on it after
f5 yeah
well i mean when i see the pawn on hc
queen on e4 and look e3
and then then i somehow believe that
this is looking very very bad
but what's the point yeah what's the
point why and the evaluation bar has
dropped
all the way down so firstly after f5 the
big threat is queen g4 check
and i can just take on f5 with the queen
yeah after gfi and uh
and white's king is just too exposed
queen g5
some ideas like group d6 sorry rookie
six rook g6 is coming here
and first you have to fight yes you have
a rookie sex rook g6 is a big idea
yeah that's that's the problem but i
mean i i don't
understand magnus it it felt to me like
he did not sense any danger it's it's
very very strange because
he usually feels these things so well
and
and his sense of danger let him down in
this game
and it's on the board gf5 had to be
played queen f5 played
saturday we're probably going to see
your idea of rookie 6 rook g6
and does this mean that daniel dubois
will make his comeback with the black
pieces that's what
that's what's going on here
yes yeah actually it's a very
interesting match yeah i mean
uh dubose clearly the fighting player
i mean he uh always gives a comeback
he's definitely so you know i let me
mention that he now i understand why
magnus tries to play always as dry as
possible against daniel yeah
because man magnus is not playing
against duo
i don't feel that he is going
deliberately so much for the end games
yeah he does it when it's necessary but
it's not like his main idea to get into
some end game but against
uh daniel whenever i see any
complications he directly goes towards
this
slightly better end game and he squeezes
it out and he gets perfect results
but in all these crazy games uh danielle
is up to the task to
to pose big headaches for magnus yeah
peter perhaps he should have uh listened
to you yeah
not taking on c6 and then playing king
jito just releasing the position
yeah yeah but i mean you know when you
hit me with this queen g5 h5
i have to admit you know i i started to
feel some danger because i
i hope that with this quincy on bishop
f1 i will very easily calmly make it
through but queen g5 h5 was
was spicing it up and queen b5 played so
how does that fight against rook e6
does white want to go rook somewhere and
but yeah maybe rookie two
no i don't know rook somewhere g6 rook
g2 everything is coming yeah
yeah white can try and run to e3
can you then queen e6 and then i will
pick up the queen on uh
e i mean on b5 with queen e6 and queen
e2
coming so let's just see that line rook
g6 white i mean white has to find a way
to escape the mate
anyway so rookie and
king e somewhere e3
oh you just go queen e6 and pick up no
queen e6 king d2 it's not over right you
play
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
h3 so you have to go king f2 yeah then i
uh
[Music]
yeah still it's not uh show me the mate
[Music]
okay i'm thinking of some super crazy
lines like queen and maybe
maybe you start with queen g5 say though
maybe you start with queen g5 rook e6
rook 86
[Music]
oh yeah yeah that's that's yeah that's
that's
clever way of doing it
and of course more computer chess from
our uh producer coming in
yeah but this also looks lost no or is
there a queen d3 check you have maybe
okay but it's just to check yeah i'm
kicking it yeah
yeah just a check okay so now daniel
knows this is the moment he has a minute
and a half peter i know you really like
this when players slow down in a winning
position take their time and find the
right path
he's doing that and uh while he does
that let's just show the line that's
being mentioned um to us so
rookie six also wins with rookie two
rook g6 check king f2 and now this is a
very difficult this is a computer move
queen f4
so difficult to spot i mean maybe in the
position you can spot it but from the
beginning it's very hard to find this
yeah well i think the reason why it's so
difficult for the human brain to find
queen f4
very quickly is that first you look at
all the check options and you are
looking for the first win yeah
and uh once you finish all those lines
only then you are
coming back to you know some small move
then you realize that you are not
check meeting but the the line with
queen g5 i mean
what is magnus really planning i know
but we are seeing this look e6
oh he played rookie six he didn't go for
queen g5 he went for rookie six
so has he found has he spotted queen f4
i'm a little surprised by this because
uh say to after queen g5 rookie six just
very hard to see how black
white is fighting the mate yeah that's
true yeah queen g5 has a clever move
like first giving a check and then okay
six no but
uh when you think yeah like okay you see
this idea of rookie six and then your
mind always goes uh with immediate two
cases yeah you never think of giving an
intermediate check yeah
especially in time trouble yes
he did take his time and now he's down
to 35 seconds has he spotted queen f4
he needs to move fast but actually you
know the point was that
maybe again queen f4 on the board with
25 seconds on the clock
then here finds it and now he jumps back
to 35 seconds
and queen f4 on the board peter daniel
is
such a beast in these positions it's
incredible the way he plays
the moves he finds i mean just
super impressive stuff yeah and let's
not forget if he wins this game and it
seems like he's about to win
then he will be white in the very last
game and he's fighting for to to take
the set
it's it's a big turnaround in the match
yeah winning is black against magnus is
an achievement kind of it's huge
and uh according to the line that we
were being told by our producer the
engine line the idea is simple queen f4
you ideally want to pick up you pick up
the pawn on h2
and you simply end up queening the pawn
after giving a few checks
so queen g one check perhaps here and
then just
but you have to be careful with hedge to
uh queen edge by check yes yeah how do
you do it
no no but i don't think uh you can you
can also play
to check instead of uh going for all
this message yeah but i think that this
is good enough no h2 queen episode
h6 and i mean
that's true but what you're saying as
well is rook g2 just mate actually after
queen d5
yeah i can go king f1 still but uh
yeah rookie one and then queen and
queenie one
very pretty and just a quick update all
other three games have ended in a draw
the hikaru levon that was a repetition
after 95 so that ended peacefully
a crazy game a very interesting one um
uh and then yan
and raja also drew their game so this is
the only one that remy
that remains and it looks like daniel's
about to make his big
comeback in this set winning with black
going into the last round with white
big pressure on the world champion
yeah absolutely i mean magnus is not
done to 50 seconds but he could even
have two hours of two weeks there is
just no defense
yeah queen b1 played finally
okay so not lying rook g2 at least it
pins it and now you go for this idea of
picking up the pawn on h2 and then white
wants to go king e3 after queen h2
yeah i also can pick up the ball on d4
yeah i mean yeah queen d4 also looks
very nice
yeah because it doesn't have the option
to go king f1 or king e1 because queen
g1 picks up the queen
so you have to go rookie repeater maybe
we can have that on the board
yeah i wanted to mention that even you
can play keemstar first
just opening the rook and you still have
all these
awesome this is peter's movie yeah king
and six is
this is like super high class chess this
is just
incredible i mean you know i feel a lot
of us would think about
grabbing the pawn with the chair exactly
so it's just so incredible to see this
happen on the board
in this position to just make a simple
move like king 86 with seconds on the
clock
yeah i think peter would also go for
king and six yeah yeah definitely i mean
first of all you know because my
question is does my opponent want
something
no thank you very much then let me just
improve my position yeah
it's very simple
yeah and and one was also down to 10
seconds but okay he just doesn't have a
move
amazing what an incredible game by
daniel
and queen d3 so
quickly picks okay what's going on here
yeah well
now he just goes rooney yeah okay take
everything and then he has to and then
he quits everything h2
queens and with that the world champion
resigns
daniel dubois leveling the match